artificial intelligence has gone from
science fiction to almost everyday
reality now and it's changing our lives
in really profound ways I think
personally speaking it's one of the most
exciting developments that I've
encountered at Wired and I'm curious
just to turn it over to both of you and
to talk about this Joe is the experts so
I'm going to defer to him but what my
general observation as you said is that
it is seeping into our lives in all
sorts of ways that we just don't notice
and part of the reason is because the
way we think about AI is colored by
popular culture and by science fiction
and I know it's a familiar distinction
to a lot of your readers between general
AI and specialized AI a specialized AI
is really the stuff that we've been
doing for quite some time we're just
getting better and better at it and that
is figuring out using algorithms whether
computers can figure out increasingly
complex tasks and we're seeing that
happen in every aspect of our lives from
medicine to transportation to how
electricity is distributed and it
promises to create a vastly more
productive and efficient economy and if
properly harnessed can generate enormous
prosperity for people opportunity for
people can cure diseases that we haven't
seen before
can make us safer because it eliminates
inherent human error in a lot of work
but it also has some downsides that
we're going to have to figure out in
terms of if not eliminating jobs
requiring people to think differently
about their occupations
it could increase inequality and we've
seen that in technology generally in
globalization it can suppress wages and
so we're going to have to develop new
social constructs in order to embrace
fully and optimize this this new
technology in science fiction where you
hear about is generalized AI right so
computers start getting smarter and we
are and eventually conclude that we're
not all that useful and then off we go
off we go you know or yeah either
they're you know drugging us and keeping
us fat and happy or you know we're in
the matrix we're living in a simulation
yeah or we're living in simulation now
yeah Joey said there's a lot more my
impression based on talking to my top
Sciences advisors is is that we're still
a reasonably long way away from that
kind of generalized AI it's worth
thinking about only because it stretches
our imaginations and it gets us to think
about what our core values and issues of
choice and free will that actually do
have some significant applications for
specialized AI but generally speaking
that's probably not the thing that we
need to worry about the most right now
we need to figure out how do we get
what's already happening around us but
it's just going to be more and more
incorporated our daily lives how do we
get that right I think this may upset
some of my students at MIT but one of
the the concerns that I have about AI is
it's been predominantly male gang of
kids mostly white who were more
comfortable talking to computers and
human beings that have been building the
core computer science around AI and not
all but a lot of them feel that if they
could just make that science fiction
general AI we wouldn't have to worry
about all the messy stuff like politics
and society and there's almost like a
church of this belief in
headquartered in Silicon Valley and so
so I that's a concern because I think a
lot of people figure that the machines
will just figure it all out right and
they underestimate the difficulty and I
feel like this is the year that
artificial intelligence becomes not just
a computer science problem but something
that the white house that I've been
working very closely with a friar in the
Dominican Order I was trying to
understand you know Bitcoin encryption
in AI from the perspective of the
Catholics and so so I think that a lot
of other people need to be involved and
the difficulty has been that the
computer science community they're not
an easy gang to talk to and so and I
think you know the white house your your
team and yourself and you've you've
probably gotten your head around this
more than any other anybody else in
history and it's good timing because I
think everybody needs to understand it
and I think that that's that's that's
that's a key piece I think it's and we
use at the Media Lab we're using the
term extended intelligence because we
don't think it's going to be us and in
AI
the AI just like Google just like
everything will be built into the laws
and to the government into society and
how that behaves is important and it's
like the Internet and when we were doing
a lot of the early work on the internet
we thought it would just solve democracy
right doctors just get better but now
you've got another more these didn't
work out so well and we do think that we
can push the pendulum back